Raphaël Jacob est avec nous maître
Steven Dreyfus ancien procureur du comté
de New York ancien président de l'Union
internationale des avocats bonsoir
maître Dreyfus
bonsoir bonsoir Raphaël je commence avec
vous maître Dreyfus là on les a là les
accusations quand on se parlait plutôt
on n'avait pas le texte est-ce que vous
diriez que c'est ça tient la route c'est
puissant comme cause qu'est-ce comment
vous pouvez nous expliquer ce que le
procureur a bâti comme théorie
donc là il faut faire la distinction
entre
l'importance du sujet
et la force de l'accusation on peut se
mettre d'accord sur le fait que parmi
les enquêtes
auxquelles monsieur Trump est confronté
on pourrait dire que celui-ci
serait la plus triviale
par rapport aux enquêtes en cours pour
avoir essayé de fausser les sur Géorgie
en ce qui concerne le 6 janvier en ce
qui concerne la dimension de documents
confidentiel et classifier il faut dire
que le sujet de cette enquête est plutôt
trivial mais on peut distinguer à la
force de l'enquête dans son cadre c'est
à dire que
j'ai l'impression que
l'épreuve seront présents et seront au
rendez-vous pour établir la culpabilité
de de notre offre à condition
que les j'aurais croient en la
crédibilité en la vérité du témoignage
notamment de de Michael Cohen et des
autres témoins mais il paraît qu'il
existe une espèce de collaboration
documentaire qui pourrait aider à la
à la faire du poker
donc
je vous oublie pas à faire donc ma
Dreyfus vous dites que ce que vous avez
vu
d'après vous pourrez mener effectivement
une condamnation criminelle envers
monsieur Trump
oui à condition que le jury croit les
témoins et et
que aussi avant le procès le juge sera
il sera présenté au juge d'émotions
cherchant à débouter le poker pour les
raisons d'insuffisance juridique il faut
voir qu'il que le procure gagne ses
motion pour qu'il y ait un procès mais
si
l'accusation perdure jusqu'au stade du
procès le procès est tout à fait
gagnable comme il est perdable aussi si
le jury ne croit pas en la vérité des
témoins Raphaël Jacob sur un sur le plan
politique on l'a beaucoup dit depuis
deux jours ce qui était avec nous plutôt
mais
les chiffres au monde que Monsieur Trump
profite de cette mise en accusation
profite massivement Patrice on compare
entre la période pré-incubation à la
période post-annonce de l'incubation
depuis jeudi soir dernier les chiffres
sont clairs ils sont immanquables
dépendant des sondages c'est une avance
que Monsieur Trump détient désormais
face à Wanda Center sont plus importants
hypothétiques rival à ce statut pour les
primaires républicaines qui a quelque
part entre doublé et tripler on parle
d'une avance moyenne présentement à peu
près 30 points pourcentage comme je vous
l'ai dit un monsieur plutôt dans la
journée Patrice je le répète pour les
gens qui joignent à nous présentements
c'est pas compliqué vous remontez au
début du système moderne et primaire
américaines que ce soit du côté
démocrate du côté républicain depuis
1972 ça fait un demi-siècle jamais je
dis jamais est-ce que une personne un
candidat a été dans une telle position
d'avance à ce stati d'une course pour
les primaires sans éventuellement
remporter de son parti autrement dit non
seulement monsieur Trump est très aidé
de façon très significative dans tout ça
mais ça la met dans une position
carrément de commande actuellement du
parti républicain question que les gens
se posent Stephen Dreyfus est-ce que
s'il était reconnu coupable en janvier
février prochain peu importe ou plus
tard
peut-il encore être candidat et à
l'investiture et à la présidentielle
mais tout à fait il y a aucune il n'y a
aucune exigence de pureté de casier jury
judiciaire pour être candidat ou même
pour être président mais la seule chose
que je dirais pour rebondir à ce que ce
que vous avez dit c'est que
effectivement si le but de notre homme
était de décrocher la nomination
républicaine
ça pourrait lui servir si par en vend
chez c'est plutôt le cas son but était
redevenir président des États-Unis il
n'est pas du tout sûr que ça lui sert
dans servent dans la direction générale
en novembre très intéressant Raphaël
Jacob donc à court terme pour
l'investiture les républicains puis on
le voit là ils font front avec lui sur
quelques exceptions ils sont avec lui or
pour l'électorat en général peut-être
que ça va faire un petit peu beaucoup à
absorber là absolument surtout que c'est
l'accumulation et surtout Patrice parce
que on parle presque exclusivement
aujourd'hui d'une cause celle stormy
Daniels carnick the wall peu importe
comment on veut la surnommer la question
des fameux paiements mais c'est une
cause sur plusieurs et un petit peu
comme être des fruits très en ouverture
de segments écoutez on s'entend là que
sur le fond il y en a qui sont nettement
plus graves par rapport auxquels ça
allait dans la spéculation là on
pourrait avoir des préoccupations donc
effectivement pour le reste de
l'électoral électorat non républicain ça
peut et ça risque de commencer à faire
pas mal je m'en signe également pour la
petite note historique ceux qui se
demandent justement comment est-ce que
c'est même concevable que quelqu'un
puisse être candidat présidentiel alors
qu'il est inculpé voire condamné il y a
un précédent quand même significatif on
rentre il y a presque exactement 100 ans
en 1920 je vais le faire brièvement mais
c'est intéressant je crois que c'est
pertinent youjin dead qui était le
candidat socialiste qui s'était prononcé
publiquement contre l'effort de guerre
américain pendant la Première Guerre
mondiale alors que c'était un crime à
l'époque de le faire avait été à la fois
occupé condamné à un fait campagne d'une
cellule de prison à Atlanta et devenez
quoi il avait réussi à tenir très loin
de 4% du vote donc un précédent mais
Dreyfus en terminant est-ce que c'est
une procédure qui risque de prendre
combien de temps
à couper dernière
question combien de temps cette
procédure pourrait-elle prendre
oui alors on a dit que éventuellement il
y aurait un date début en date en
janvier 2004 pour un procès
ce serait avoir parce que ça dépend
d'émotion se dépend de du temps qu'il
faudrait pour le juge de trancher mais
s'il y avait un CV un procès en janvier
on serait alors en pleine campagne
électorale plutôt des primaires mais
très vite l'élection générale ça
pourrait durer devant jury ça pourrait
durer
[Musique]
trois semaines en mois
je me lance dans le néant mais ça peut
ça peut durer longtemps et
ça il est obligatoire que l'accusé soit
présent chaque jour du fossé donc ça
pourrait éventuellement clouer de notre
homme sur place à New York pour des
raisons qui ne lui sauront pas forcément
aimable
aussi je peux dire ainsi mettre même
quand vous vous lancez dans le néant
votre néant est plus éclairé que le
nôtre parce que vous avez travaillé à
cette cour merci d'avoir été là Raphaël
Jacob on se reparle à de multiples
reprises au cours des prochains jours
merci beaucoup à vous deux bonne soirée